there is no type of fame quite like the
one actors are thrust into after
starring in a Marvel movie with
international attention can also come
backlash of equal intensity and sadly
seven-year-old Avengers endgame actress
Lexi rabe is currently facing the
negative effects of being part of the
Marvel Cinematic Universe let us repeat
that the internet is bullying a
seven-year-old
what was wrong with you people people
have reportedly begun harassing rape who
plays Morgan Stark the adorable daughter
of Robert Downey jr. 'he's Tony Stark
and Gwyneth Paltrow's Pepper Potts and
Avengers endgame though no specific
incidents of bullying have been
explicitly mentioned it seems that the
harasser z' became upset over rapes
behavior when they saw her in public
finding fault with her acting quote
silly and evidently declining to take
photos with them rave and her mother
Jessica addressed the unfortunate
situation in a video uploaded two rapes
Instagram account
Jessica rave wrote in the caption that
quote yet again Lexi's getting bullied
and asked everyone to please withhold
their opinions about her daughter so
that she can quote grow up in the free
world in the clip
Lexia seen apologizing for not being
perfect reminding people that she's just
a young girl hi and once a week I'm only
7 years old and I mess up sometimes
Jessica rave elaborated in the caption
she's a normal human being and she's a
child we give her a talking and we give
her time outs but we don't do that in
public
sometimes we're rushing from place to
place stressed like everyone else could
get to set on time or work or whatever
and we seem a little grumpy I'm sorry if
you see us this way but that's life if
you ask us for an autograph we almost
always say yes if we happen to be having
a bad day that might put us right on the
right we are not perfect she also noted
that contrary to what some may believe
Lexie is a well-behaved child and if she
wasn't Marvel probably wouldn't have
hired her for Avengers end game raves
mother then requested that people
refrain from passing judgments or making
harsh remarks until they have children
of their own and asked that they
realized the rape family is quote not
perfect and isn't claiming to be she
ended the caption with a heartwarming
reminder that quote
my children love me and respect me even
if they act out sometimes Thank You
Jessica
at the end of the video Lexi who still
had a smile on her face despite all the
backlash then tugged on heartstrings
when she delivered the iconic line from
endgame to those who have supported her
I love you Lea thousand when it was
announced earlier this year that orange
is the new black alum Ruby Rose had
landed the role of bad woman on the
small screen disgruntled fans raised
their proverbial pitchforks and claimed
that she was the wrong choice for the
part
the Australian actress deleted her
Twitter account when the negativity
became overwhelming if cruel criticism
can push adult actors to step away from
the limelight
it can only be much much worse for a
young girl like rave who has never been
exposed to anger an animosity like this
before
thankfully the morgan stark actress
seems to be surrounded by a strong and
loving family who will keep her spirits
high and outside negativity low check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]